-Welcome back, everybody.
I'm here with my co-host,
Demi Lovato!
[ Cheers and applause ]
New album out this Friday.
It is time to play
"Can You Feel It?"
Eww!
-♪ "Can You Feel It?" ♪
Alright, here's how this works.
We're going to have a number of
mystery objects brought out
in front of us, and our job
is to guess what is in each one.
The catch is that we have to
figure it out by touch alone.
We don't even
see what's in the box.
Are you ready for this?
-No.
-I know. Me neither.
I don't know why
we're playing this again,
because we've done this,
and I really can't
stand this game.
But alright.
But, Demi,
since we're co-hosting --
Oh, I'll start things off?
[ Laughs ]
I thought it was going to say,
since we're co-hosting,
you start it off.
I guess I'm going to
start it off.
Alright.
Let's get the first object.
Here we go.
♪♪
We're going to have 30 seconds
to identify what this is.
[ Audience "Ohhs" ]
Audience, don't do that,
'cause this is
exactly what happens.
They start "oohing" and "aahing"
and "awwing," and -- Oh, gosh.
-Oh, man!
-Alright,
that doesn't help me at all.
Alright, we have 30 seconds --
ugh! -- to identify what it is.
I can't even think.
I'm so bummed out right now.
Alright. Aah!
Aah!
♪♪
-It's going to get you!
-Aah! Ow, ow, ow, ow!
It was like a wet nose.
Like a wet nose in there.
There's a wet nose that,
like, licked me or something.
Gross!
Aah!
Gosh!
Alright, it's light.
It's light, so there's nothing
alive in here -- maybe!
-Maybe. You don't know.
-Oh, God!
♪♪
Stop.
Someone just yelled,
and I'm freaking out!
Aah! Aah!
I'm really --
I'm seriously freaking out.
Ugh!
[ Buzzer ]
Alright, I'm out.
What in the -- What is it?
It did move!
[ Sad tuba plays ]
-It did move.
-It was moving.
-This thing is ridiculous.
I cannot...
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Feel my heartbeat.
-[ Laughs ]
-Alright, Demi, you're up.
Because you're my co-host,
you're very lucky.
You get the second one.
-Cool.
-Yeah.
And we up
the craziness on each box.
Aah!
-No!
-Aaaah!
-[ Laughing ] No!
-Aaaaah!
-No! No!
No! I hate that.
-No, you love it.
[ Drumroll ]
-My heart's beating
really fast now.
Do I just do one hand or both?
-You can go for it.
-Oh, my God.
Wait.
It's slimy! I hate it!
Is there hair? What is this?
Oh, my God!
Is it -- Oh, it's like --
It's Jell-O.
-Wow!
-It's Jell-O.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
[ Dinging ]
Oh, it's got a troll inside.
-But how are we -- anyone ever
supposed to guess this?
A troll inside a Jell-O mold?
-Yeah, I was not
going to get that.
-Who would ever
guess that thing? Alright.
I would say you're lucky
you get to go twice,
but it's my turn now.
Alright, let's bring it in.
Alright.
Oh, man, I really...
[ Breathes deeply ]
Alright.
-Oh, this is not good.
This is not good.
I would hate that.
[ Laughs ]
You might want to
roll up your sleeves.
-Oh, man!
Don't say that to me.
Gosh!
-Oh, my God. The way...
[ Laughs ] I know!
♪♪
[ Laughter ]
-Aah! Wait.
So, I almost touched it there?
-Wait. Wait.
-Everyone started clapping.
They were, like, freaking out,
because I almost touched it.
-Right...
Right...
Closer.
There you go.
-Aah! It stung me!
It stung me!
Something stung me!
Oh! Oh! Bleeding!
I'm bleeding!
What is it?! It's gross!
Did that move?
I'm looking at what it...
[ Buzzer ]
[ Sad tuba plays ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
I can't even...
It's unbelievable. It moved.
I can't --
Both of my things moved.
Your thing did not move.
Demi, lucky you. You're up.
Maybe you get to go twice.
♪♪
-Yeah, but it ups
the ante every time?
-That's right. Yes, we do.
-So I'm not looking forward
to this at all.
[ Audience groans ]
No! Don't do that.
You can't dance.
That's not fair.
I didn't dance
when you were up here.
Okay. Here we go.
I'm shaking.
-You got this.
-Oh, my God.
Why is it --
There's heat radiating.
-No, no. You got this.
-Is it in my head?
-You got it.
-Wet!
Oh! Wait.
Oh, oh, it's water.
[ Laughter ]
-It's water with rubber duckies.
-Oh.
[ Dinging ]
-It's unbelievable.
-That's cute.
-I'm so mad.
This is why --
This how much more
my writers love you than me.
Little rubber duckies in water.
I got the grossest --
What even was that?
SpaghettiOs
spitting out of a volcano?
[ Laughter ]
Thank goodness
this is the last one.
We're going to touch the
same item at the same time.
We're going to get --
First person to guess it wins.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-That's never good.
-No, no.
[ Both laugh ]
I'm gonna freak out.
♪♪
-It's hot. I can feel heat.
-It's hot, right?
-Oh, no! What is that?
-I don't know! I don't know!
-It's hairy!
-No, it's not!
No, it's not!
-No, it's hairy!
-It's hairy?! No!
[ Both scream ]
-No! Oh, my God!
-What is it?
[ Laughter ]
Come here, come here, come here.
It's Kenan Thompson.
-Did you not know?
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I'm freaking out.
I'm so happy it's you.
-You didn't know?
-I'm so happy it's you.
-I wanted to bite you.
-Kenan Thompson, everybody!
Oh, my gosh.
We're talking to Kenan
after the break.
Stick around, everybody.
Thank you, Demi.